Você
está sempre cansado ou cansada, como se
sua energia estivesse presa no modo
bateria viciada, dorme, mas acorda
quebrado, toma café, mas continua no
mesmo marasmo? Talvez o problema não
esteja no seu humor, nem no seu
estresse. Talvez esteja dentro das suas
células. Um estudo de 2025 do Journal of
Clinical Endocrinology mostrou que mais
60% dos adultos acima de 40 anos tem
deficiência de magnésio intracelular,
mesmo com exames de sangue normais. É
aquele tipo de deficiência invisível,
mas devastadora paraas suas
mitocôndrias. E é aqui que começa a
história que eu vejo se repetir todos os
dias no consultório. Paciente chega
esgotado, tem todos os exames,
hemograma, ferro, TSH, vitamina D, tudo
normal. sai com prescrição de
ansiolítico ou um e só estresse. Só que
o corpo não mente. Eu peço o magnésio
eritrocitário e lá está deficiência
severa. O sangue mente, a célula não. O
erro está no próprio exame. Apenas 1%
magnésio total circula no sangue. O
resto mora dentro das células. É como
olhar a vitrine da loja e decretar que o
estoque tá cheio, ignorando o depósito
vazio. A medicina convencional se
satisfaz com magnésio sérico. Eu quero
ver o que está acontecendo lá dentro,
onde a energia de verdade é produzida. E
aqui entra o ponto crucial. Mitocôndria,
seus motores celulares para produzir
ATP, sua moeda energética, elas dependem
de magnésio como cofator essencial e
mais de 300 reações bioquímicas. E há um
detalhe importante que muita gente
conhece biologicamente o ATP
praticamente não existe sozinho. Ele
existe como magnésio ATP. Sem magnésio
suficiente, o seu corpo entra no que eu
chamo de modo economia de energia. Você
funciona mais engasgado igual um carro
velho tentando subir uma ladeira sem
força. Um estudo de março de 2025 na
revista Nutrients acompanhou 240
pacientes com fadiga inexplicada. Metade
recebeu magnésio trionato metade
placebo. O grupo suplementando
apresentou aumento de 34%
na produção de ATP muscular e 73%
relatou melhora a clara de energia. Isso
é bioquímica aplicada e não é efeito
psicológico. Mas aqui vem o golpe que a
maioria sofre. A suplementação errada.
Comprar óxido de magnésio barato é como
comprar o laxante caro. Ele não chega ao
interior da célula, não melhora energia
e gera apenas diarreia. A escolha da
forma certa é o primeiro passo e o
timing é o segundo. Eu vou te mostrar o
protocolo que eu aplico aqui na minha
clínica lapidada após acompanhar mais de
500 pacientes com fadiga crônica. Pela
manhã usamos formas que alimentam o
ciclo de crebes. O magnésio de malato é
excelente para isso, porque o malato
participa diretamente do processo
energético. A dose de apoio varia entre
200 mg e 300 mg no magnésio alimentar e
é ignição do dia. No meio da tarde,
quando o corpo começa a entrar naquele
limbo de cansaço com irritabilidade,
usamos magnésio bisglicinato, cerca de
200 mg. A glicina tem efeito calmante e
ajuda na modulação do sistema nervoso,
preparando transição pra noite. E antes
de dormir, entramos com mais 200 mg de
bisiglicinato ou citrato ou treonato,
especialmente se houver constipação.
Então esse fracionamento é fundamental
para manter os níveis celulares
constantes, evitando picos intestinais
que desperdiçam o mineral. Mas existe um
parceiro indispensável, vitamina B6
ativa, a peridoxal c fosfato. É o
porteiro que abre a porta da célula pro
magnésio entrar. Sem ela, você toma o
magnésio, ele simplesmente não é
internalizado. Estudos mostram que a
combinação magnésio mais P5P poroxal cic
fosfato, aumenta a eficiência da
repracelular
em até 2,3 vezes. Então eu uso entre 25
e 50 mg junto da dose da manhã.
Existem sinais clínicos clássicos de
deficiência. O mais emblemático é a
faciculação pompebral, aquele tremor
chato na pálpebra que aparece em aviso.
Câimbras noturnas, palpitações benignas,
fadiga ao acordar, ansiedade se motivo
claro e dificuldade de concentração
também indicam carência. Outro inimigo
silencioso é o estresse crônico.
Cortisol elevado aumenta a perda
urinária de magnésio. É um ciclo
vicioso. Estresse reduz magnésio. Falta
de magnésio aumenta a sensibilidade ao
estresse. Para quebrar esse ciclo,
trabalhamos com doses divididas que
totalizam 600 mg de magnésio alimentar
por dia durante 8 a 12 semanas. Não
podemos ignorar fatores modernos, solos
empobrecidos, alimentos mais pobres em
minerais, excesso de cafínica, álcool,
além de medicamentos que drenam
magnésio, comoepraszol, diuréticos e
anticoncepcionais. Para muitos
pacientes, suplementar deixou de ser
escolha e virou necessidade fisiológica.
O processo de repessão não é rápido,
leva de 8 a 12 semanas para as células
saturarem os toques. A melhora começa
discreta, cresce gradualmente e se
estabiliza no terceiro mês. Depois
disso, entramos em manutenção com dose
de 200 a 300 mg. A fadiga crônica,
muitas vezes, é simplesmente o grito de
uma mitocôndria desnutrida. E a
diferença entre sobreviver arrastado ou
viver com energia real pode estar na
correção meticulosa de um único mineral.
Agora saia do vídeo se você prefere
superficialidade, porque o que eu vou te
dizer a seguir, não posso aprofundar
aqui. O YouTube e o conselho me limitam.
Na comunidade fechada, porém, não há
filtros. Lá eu entrego integralmente os
protocolos que eu uso na prática
clínica, interpretações avançadas de
exames, combinações fla, estudos
destrinchados e fornecedores confiáveis.
é acesso direto ao meu raciocínio
clínico atualizado semanalmente. Além
disso, no nível dois, fazemos imersões
em 15 anos de 2 horas, debatendo artigos
linha por linha e explorando
controvérsias que ninguém toca. Se você
quer apenas assistir esse canal, basta.
Se deseja pertencer ao ciclo interno que
está redefinindo a medicina funcional do
Brasil, clique em seja membro. Poucos
têm essa coragem. Você, eu acho que tem.
Agradecimentos especiais a nossos
membros queridos dos estudos avançados
da comunidade fechada do YouTube. Nível
dois, Dr. Ana Paulo Rodrigues, José
Fortunato Burtinho, Fernando Machado,
Sou Jucioli, Cristina Carol, Romana
Moraril, Estela Mares, Eloterapias
Integrativas, Luís Anselmo Neves Antes
da Doença. Eu agradeço de coração pelo
apoio prestado.